so how's the novel coming up we always
get to encourage the [__] huh what do we
got over there just your name no C plus
J equals forever oh
Jonathan not blue face
how many Jonathan related tattoos do we
have now
I thought she was gonna say three I know
right she said I just have seven I do
that's I'm stopping yeah
that's what you're saying you don't like
it
hello
that's why I be tripping okay when did
you realize
that
because the last time we did an
interview was like right after when and
I was still well I was still giving it
was like a year and a half ago it was
like right after the whole G-Wagon [__]
popped off right right and and you drove
the G wagon across the country
and so I was like it looked like oh well
[__] this is a bad situation when did
you kind of come to the realization that
man this girl's literally crazy in love
for me and we need to like you know
explore
our relationships
huh he was mad but he missed me that's
what happened
like when and then he missed me
we didn't know he was gonna get over it
that's not what he asked go ahead no I
mean like what happened
we didn't really get back together we
just started missing me I was gonna say
like when did you realize like
this she's the one I'm gonna be with
she's the one I'm gonna you know
in Chicago
I think it was like
like last summer
like literally like recently April and
what were you when you first saw that
this tattoo blue it's a thing right
there you know that's a that's a real
sign of love
what was your reaction
you give a [__] about it did you
I thought it was a dope [__] I thought
[__]
your Christian face tattoos coming soon
I will do it for him I don't care why
would a face tattoo type of person you
literally have Benjamin Franklin's face
tattooed on your body twice I'm looking
at both of them right now
why are you trying to believe me like
that kid that's crazy trying to be funny
just say for real be for real yeah
that's crazy you're like I wouldn't get
Noah's face tattooed on my body except
an old white man who died 200 years ago
oh by the way his [__] Mike
well listen man I'm excited for y'all to
uh step into uh Parenthood together
why don't you give me a kiss you don't
deserve one
look what you didn't do listen remember
everything's about the kid you guys got
my little rock rock man you guys got a
[__] this whole video you guys got a
baby on the way so I'm excited for y'all
to be uh obviously parents to a new kid
oh yeah foreign
when is the due date do we know
none your damn business all right well
shout out to Christian rock and blueface
season two of Crazy In Love summertime
baby soon music soon I'm high bro don't
take this interview too serious it's all
good man appreciate y'all pulling up
Krishan thank you for not breaking
anything except
the table I'll take that yeah that's
good that's like a message that actually
this table's gonna be worth a million
dollars yep I had an auction there it is
we're gonna frame it right if we ever
get rid of the table we're gonna cut
that square out and put it on the wall
thanks for coming through though boom